[Music]
welcome back to all the record what are
we talking about whatever
let's go let's go cheers everybody
welcome
back your bastard son of jk fun fact
nick steals dude nick [ __ ] steals
he stole some [ __ ] from you you guys
steal so [ __ ] much what are you doing
his [ __ ] wife
outed him out so bad this was been
stealing from target for years
do you need more money no this is not
recently bro hey this is not richard
nick steele was tough for personal
trainers i know yeah it was it was rough
no no this was like when i first started
training and i started first started
fighting i was like a student
how old are you dude this is last year
this is like 2020 yeah
now this was uh like 20 years ago 14
2013 okay
okay it's way more recent pretty recent
though yeah i'm actually shocked we
thought it was like 2010.
i thought it was going to be like 2000
is this the date that's beyond the
statute of limitations
yeah it was 1992. okay good okay last
night
i was shopping for some uh i was
shopping for some tights
you know because i i needed you stole
leggings you're doing macbeth
i had a big performance i stole a skull
this stuff is very important and i saw
there was 35
and i was like i'm not going to pay 35
for these because i've had these tights
before and they ripped so i was like i'm
not going to pay 35
why do you want to get the same ones
that ripped hey because so so guess what
hey guess what guess what
so i was like unreliable car before i
get another one if i can get it for free
then it's all good
right it's not free stolen cool yeah
that's true okay
so uh i put them i went to the dressing
room put them on put them all
and then i just walked out and it was
that's the end of the story but my wife
decided to we're all working out with
dave one day she ratting you out
out of nowhere dude we're like doing a
set and then she turns to dave and goes
you know nick you steal it from target
why why i don't know bro i don't know
and she started
laughing it was like something she
couldn't wait to see what did you do
that night did they blow us up like that
was i don't know that was nothing
does mickey do that to you oh [ __ ] yeah
she [ __ ] liked my ass out of nowhere
get ready bro this is what's going to
happen it ain't going to happen i got
too much junk on it
we were literally doing like chess flies
it's like one set she goes
nick steals from target
where did this come from there was no
context no conversation before
that was years ago that was like she's
just waiting to get it off her chest
just like i need to tell someone i was
like 20 years old is that her first time
having a conversation
bro honestly i she needs to be here so
she can defend herself
dude she should be on the stand no you
need to grab her by the ear if i can
pull her to the side and go this is not
how you [ __ ] talk in public
what if it's like he's not the man you
think you know
[Laughter]
all his [ __ ] has ink stains on it
explodes that's why i never wear white
bro i never wear white it's always black
no wonder you're one of us i i was like
this guy
he grew up in pasadena not around asians
i don't steal from target
no we stole though yeah hey i
that's what i mean like everyone here
stole but everybody used to kind of but
i did it on accident but i thought you
were offering
i don't steal i stole an accident
because i was i was on the phone
and i was in a grocery store getting a
toothbrush because i was with my
girlfriend's parents in santa barbara
and i was like [ __ ] i forgot my
toothbrush and i was on the phone with
my buddy and we're talking about this
stupid idea that we were working on and
i just walked out of the store with a
toothbrush and i got all the way back to
her
parents place and i was like with a
toothbrush too
got chills yeah i was like i was gonna
be a criminal right there guys
i'm a criminal stole a wallet from
target like that really
yeah from a guy's pocket yeah i wish
dude i [ __ ] wish it was one of those
magic wallets when you flip it it grabs
the dollar yeah those are cool
elastic on the inside yeah but it
doesn't make it okay that you stole your
piece of [ __ ] and i kept playing with it
and i walked out with it and i had it in
my car and for
four weeks i was like who left their
[ __ ] empty wallet here
with the price tag on it that says there
was no time are you guys ready for a
[ __ ] crazy story
there's a pair of red underwear found in
my
office where we do laundry and it's not
nikki's
at your house at my place wait your
office in my office
yeah and you're speaking about this on
camera why no no because it's
it's a genuinely confusing thing how did
that underwear show up
in your office stevie [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know it looks like
hey bro hey this guy's a bird you know
guys if a
equals b and b c so the question is am i
sleep pulling or like what's going on
hey those quick ferguson videos been
pulling off is your marriage on the
rocks
dude i've been nagging non-stop i'm
making tricks
everybody up clean it up you really
found these yeah really are they like
of this of this time they are it's not
yeah it's not granny pants so they're
modern day panties
they worn out they were just in the
laundry pile meanwhile nikki's like oh
my god where did you get that that's not
mine
oh that's exactly what happened but wait
what are you saying
i'm not picking up something i'm sorry
what did you smell them to see
who would have been fresh because they
were they were done i had done all the
laundry and they're not hers they're not
nicki's that's what she says
i don't know what our nikkies are not i
assume because they're girl underwear
they fit her
they probably would have i thought plot
twist nikki caught covenant from bard
again
and she has memory loss
that's what it is dude and she bought
him on that day has any of us gotten
covered without bar being involved by
the way that's true
[ __ ] wag you over there
i literally had a flash of when i had
kovitz and i specifically remember him
with his coveted hands going try this
steak
he put it in his head and he stuck it
right in my mouth did it also have
charcoal on his fingers
he put it in my mouth and it was covered
directly i mean what did you do did you
lick your [ __ ] fingers before you
went like this and gave it to david he
was coughing on a bunch of stuff
if you grab if you grab steak to give it
to somebody let's say with your hands
right
how many fingers do you i wouldn't do
that but how many fingers would you use
two
he used all five somehow he was like
this
just literally grabbed the steak he goes
try the steak
he was like hey eat this piece of
seaweed yeah i wasn't professionally
trained
as a chef no they they that's that's
that's a real training bro
the steak was delicious though it's good
right see was it worth it
it was pretty worth it wasn't it the pre
pre-cooked steak
or was it did you not know the steak i
made myself oh okay
did you order it yeah everything else
was from costco yeah yeah don't sleep on
costco catering and stuff
it's very good i had been and now i
won't yeah why do you steal though
yeah yeah what's up with that why are
you bringing it back to that is right
yeah come on man i'm trying to i'm
trying seriously i thought you were a
good person
it's in my dna bro yeah can we talk
about how i might how i maybe still
crush puss
yeah yeah dude why do you keep crushing
puss
yeah she genuinely is like these are not
mine and we're both like
is it is it her size penny though she's
obviously banging somebody else
he's a chick dude it's not somebody else
really not about you dude
that's the whole point what's the most
likely situation of this happening
like family members hey this guy's just
crushing please gross your puzzle
got it you know yeah but that's right
like walking into a [ __ ] bar with
your eyes
i'm sleepwalking
[Laughter]
that's why we do laundry in my office
you know sometimes
if the laundry washing thing is hooked
it gets
stuff gets stuck in there so it could be
from someone else like
socks towels all the thing that can drop
through the drain stairs
from the water i don't know the water
pipes whoa
i never thought of that you do the
laundry in the house or you guys uh we
usually switch off but i mostly do it
yeah
i'm not allowed to do laundry anymore
what'd you do that happened to me but
but i ruined enough of her clothes
i just keep [ __ ] up she hates it well
she has also has
like a specific schedule that she wants
to do laundry so like if i do it i do it
in bigger batches but if she wants
specific clothes she doesn't what she
wants
so it's not done on time so she decides
to do it herself why does the time
matter
i don't know everything's about time for
her there's a part of me that's
listening to this and i'm like
that's awesome i know right you're like
not allowed to do it
sick that's the key though you [ __ ] up
so hard they don't want you to do it
anymore
they think you're too stupid to do it
they'll do it forever i mean this is a
little don't send this to any girls
obviously this is a little tip though
yeah
it kind of works i suck at everything
bro that she just got really sad yeah if
we even needed to talk to you about that
bro you're [ __ ] you're [ __ ] trash
that's weirdly introspective dude hey
sidebar though just randomly like a week
ago
bro you used to be [ __ ] hella fat
david is just coming back just straight
airing everyone's dirty
this guy had material bro he's writing
he's like by the way you
you yeah
hey you couldn't wait to say that [ __ ]
this guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
is that next steal from you
you're too predictable random [ __ ] on
random [ __ ]
there was a random photo that popped up
with you you were really fat
hey i i actually got [ __ ] because um i
talked about eating a hooker's [ __ ]
and then and then and then thank you for
what the that that was the worst
non-sequitur compared to what you did
so wait why how did you get [ __ ] from
that because they were turned on when
they heard the story oh
this person's dangerous hot commodity
dog you're hot it's just another girl
wait a minute
i mean it was uh inconvenient and
yo how fat were you i wasn't fat well he
was fat this would look gross dude
you know like certain people who are who
can't be fat he's one of them
like you are not allowed to be fat it
just doesn't look right
today's video is brought to you by omen
dude when we were filming just kidding
party i wish we had something like this
because
imagine if we can play jack box games
and be able to stream
along with our fan base you could get
your own private oasis
on the omen gaming hub oasis is a free
and easy to use add-on on the omen
gaming hub and you could invite up to 15
of your friends in a private
gaming group so you could either play
like jack box games together
you could stream like do a watch party
maybe even play some like
mafia that would be pretty fun yeah and
has super low latency
so you can still get in good quality
720p 30 frames per second
and you're not gonna have all these
technical issues like oh no wait
what happened did someone just get
killed in mafia you're gonna be right
then
and there and you can screen share too
and also you can either use your voice
or text
there's so many things you can do so
make sure you have the omen gaming hub
installed
then get the oasis add-on to build your
own private paradise
so play together watch together share
together chat together
with all of your friends with oasis on
the omen
gaming hub and you can download for free
try the beta right now at bit
dot l y slash oasis record that's bit
dot
l y slash oasis record you can try the
beta for free get all your friends on
there you have to worry about all these
crazy randos
coming into your room anymore bye-bye
this is before the tick tick tour right
how does he know you're right before the
two things
you weren't at the big ticket it was
literally right before because at the
tick tick toy was
right when i just lost weight how much
did you weigh before we need a before
and after
what was the most i was in an
inspirational story how was your weight
now
uh 175 that's amazing damn 45 pounds
[ __ ] 35 210 right
is it 45. 55. don't ask us bro
it sounds like 45 pounds 175 to 200 is
25 plus 10 is 35. no bro
i go with bart hey you know i lost
[ __ ] 45 pounds
45. so when did you start hating fat
people
you never hate fat people you hate
yourself oh he just turned it around on
me
yeah but you're also a fat shamer so
explain why that's okay
why do you hate fat people why are you
racist too
why'd you leave red panties at my house
yeah and why did you wear the red
candies and leave it at his house
oh that's the twist is that i wear red
panties oh
why do you sleep you just put them on
and then you masturbate in
feel what is this but seriously though
you lost a lot of weight i was i was
thoroughly shocked i would have never
thought you were a fat person
yeah i don't know i think i just uh um
there was a moment it was like 2009 2010
where i was like not dancing uh
post-college
i never thought about dancing as a
career when i was in college and then
after college i just went into sales and
[ __ ]
so like i really just let myself go i
had no dancing was just a hobby
and then after i went into sales i ended
up becoming blah blah blah fast forward
and
now i'm at um i'm in a marketing
position for a street clothing brand
where i'm around a lot of dancers all
the time i got back into the dance
community as a marketing director for a
clothing brand
i was doing you know like collabs and
random like campaigns
and then just being back in it i uh okay
actually let me cut to the real [ __ ]
i got really really tough in my
relationship where uh things weren't
working out well and you know when
things don't work out well you kind of
like turned into like you zone out until
like working out
that's what really happened so you did
it for women you got big from
the marketing job because you're eating
out all the time i was complacent too i
was in a long-term relationship she's
amazing and all that stuff but you know
i got complacent with and just thinking
that i was she didn't fire nuts hard
enough
yeah so that did she have a problem with
your weight did she ever just look at
you one day and be like
disgusting no she like totally was fine
with me with everything before i think
everything was just
i think it was just all me when you're
marketing man you're doing all this like
nine to five [ __ ] right
do you go into the bathroom or the break
room and just do a little like and
you're like i still
[Laughter]
i steal got it this is what i'm trying
to do
you know everything you wash your hands
i think your boss kind of caught you
with your life but he still has it
it's like 100 true right the abs like
that's not
you have a [ __ ] suit and tie on wait
so you do that
your boss calls you and you go into the
office like that
yes sir dance was trying to get out dude
he was trying to get out
yes uh no joke pathetically yes
so you left your well she was very
supportive of you in your disgusting
state
she was very supportive she saw me when
i was skinnier this guy emphasizes the
disgusting phase in your life
she was amazing you said she's quite
amazing and you left her she's an
awesome person
uh very amicable man she was probably a
[ __ ] that's why you left her
yeah i don't know joe let him know why
did you leave the supportive woman who
cared about you
is the grass always greener we mutually
just kind of like we're just growing and
going into different places but you know
just in that time i don't know i think
you know when like guys
uh get out of relationships suddenly
they hit the gym just kind of go crazy i
felt like i was like mentally
checking out of the relationship even
though we weren't officially ended you
know
but david's the opposite he's in the
relationship but he lost lost weight
i got out and i lost weight but that's
because it's a good secure relationship
yeah i mean yeah i was just i was also
dying
my doctor said you are dying
measures your bone density your fat and
your muscles so the green area
is the fat and the red is the muscles
right all green
christmas tree
the red was an ornament
it legit like looked like a heat
infrared map or it was just all green on
this you know i mean
it just looked terrible and i didn't
realize how fat i was and then you look
at that [ __ ] and it puts into numbers
how much like fat that you have
and it was a lot then you start going to
doctors they start making comments about
your dad after going to tsa and they're
like hey can we talk for a second
hey man like yeah like wow we're worried
about it
why do you do this so i'm worried about
you i just started lifting my arms up
and sweating immediately
you sure you're out of breath as you
raise your arms we've asked nothing of
you
how are you already sweating i just kept
getting pulled over they thought i was
smuggling [ __ ] oh jesus you've got a lot
of jello on you brother
hey buddy i know fat shaming anthony
everybody hey
to lose weight i didn't even do it like
a healthy way oh what did you do
i just did uh whatever made the most
sense to lose the weight it wasn't even
about getting healthier or stronger it
was just about losing fat because i was
fashioning myself
how did you do it most people do it
though i got i got a tip from a guy who
uh
meth and treadmill almost great combo
okay but
he was saying that he was he was saying
like wrestlers like uh lose weight by
instead of just like running all day
because i [ __ ] hated running i still
hate running
he's like if you just walk power walk
uphill on a treadmill
you technically burn the same amount of
calories but you can endure
the uh the length right so like he's
like can you run for like
an hour i'm like [ __ ] no i can't
remember like 15 minutes right
but can you like walk uphill for like 30
minutes or an hour it's like yeah i can
and you lose the same amount of calories
so i ended up going to the gym twice a
day
just to walk just to uphill to try wow
and then i also like was like religious
about going to el pollo loco to get the
skinless
uh breast meal skin with chicken breasts
damn you're really about it
yeah that's okay what david did and then
at the second every single time i went
to the gym the second time of the day
afterwards i was oh it also hit the
sauna for 15 minutes so it wasn't even
about
i don't know i i it wasn't about health
it was just about shrinking health i was
just like i need to get this [ __ ]
fat off me somebody come you just didn't
walk outside why'd you get a gym
membership just to walk inside
were you more easier it's more
encouraging but the treadmill is more
encouraging
yeah because you other people mean it
the treadmill what do you do about
treadmill boredom genuinely yes
yes treadmill boredom like you watch the
tv or whatever tv on your phone you
watch random [ __ ]
i don't know i can't do that you just
[ __ ] look at fat photos of yourself
and you're like [ __ ] it i'll keep going
another five minutes dad you hated
yourself that much
it wasn't that bad but at the same time
yeah
well sadness everybody it's a sadness
sadness there's better ways to do it
we're beautiful when you are fat
and you're okay now the best thing about
anthony pouring that shot is he was
saying well i was that was because i
hated myself
[Laughter]
perfect timing [ __ ] dave and so bro
he's back yeah i just been giving people
[ __ ] that's what i do baby who's next
yeah
who's on the chopping block let's go to
you david you didn't do bart oh yeah
it's going to be
amazing [ __ ] you gave us all cove dude
you're welcome you're welcome you're
immune now yeah
everybody treated me like i was a
[ __ ] leper for months
nobody wanted to be around me i was like
hey guys i survived they're like yeah
right i hope you die dude
what's up they're like yeah you gotta
cope with [ __ ] you and i'm like
sorry i got close i survived i'm living
what the [ __ ] yeah
it's pretty common a lot of people get
it you got you wouldn't have known
me if cause the next day after the mike
tyson fight i was like
you know my throat feels kind of funny
and then jill's like you need to tell
everyone right now i'm like what do you
mean i didn't get the covetous i don't
know if i'm positive he goes yeah but
there's
he was about to go snowboarding there's
this thing called a pandemic going
around so
if you have anything that's even
slightly you probably have the social
responsibility to tell people
i'm like nah nah i'm good and then he
invited us over after
and then we i almost went i was supposed
to go but you shoulda went dude would
have got it you should have went you
would have got the vaccine
my wife would have murdered me bro she
was like we're not gonna go
and i go okay we're not gonna go she was
nervous about it
i don't know man she's a [ __ ] though
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that's probably why she rather go
outside about the target thing because
you've been calling her a [ __ ] lately
yeah she knows what she knows what's up
dude she knows what's up i just can't
believe you stole dude i was i'm
actually very grateful
what did you steal bro have you ever
stolen i stole the hearts of many
that's [ __ ] that was a what else
that's the best is you're doing the
stand-up set you do that joke there's
nothing
yeah okay um so
what's next we were literally talking
about this how
because you know i plan to go back into
that maybe like a year from now right
but one of the worst feelings ever is
when there's like
the ratio of how many bad shows that you
get right it's going to happen you do 10
shows in a row
most likely half of them is not going to
be that great the worst part is when
there's no break in between it's like
bad said cool i'm gonna go to the next
place that's another bad thing
and it's like all right the next place
nobody laughed again i woke up
a bad crowd that crowd everywhere
background everywhere yeah and nobody
knows how to lie there's no good crowds
but that's like the hardest part yeah
it's the hardest part sometimes these
sets don't hit
but you know there's days where you just
double down and you find out these jokes
don't work but you keep trying because
you think you're funny
i've seen some of those comics sadness
and i'm not i'm so scared of that [ __ ]
dude hey to being glass cannons huh hey
here we go
yay hey i can sure dish it out but
[ __ ] i don't want to take it it's
[ __ ] brutal
that was hilarious michael just popped
out at the end
you gotta take a [ __ ]
[Music]
you